this week i will be working on styling
my portfolio page
this code week starts
on thursday i just came back from short
break from coding holidays are great and
relaxing is awesome but it's so awesome
to come back to daily code routine today
i am going back to styling my portfolio
in the evening i will go to yes we tag
meetup
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just going for yes we take meetup
come with me
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is how the page looks right now
it's a friday in the evening
i styled it a bit i added variables so i
used variables in sas
and
i also styled the buttons i also chose
different colors um and action color i'm
still wondering if i will use these
plain colors
there's one thing i don't like
is this section i mean
this section uh clicking applications
website design and they will open um
these uh portfolio items but the thing
is that i don't like how it's styled
right now and so i'll have to rethink it
but it's going for the next week these
will be internal pages and all of these
buttons lead to external ones i
differentiated the way they look so
these are the buttons and here
it's a bit different design and it looks
more like the text um
i'm not satisfied with this gray
portfolio part
but i will think it later i also added
twitter today
for this week that's it i will you know
this is the basic styling i will have to
rethink
um
i will have to rethink this portfolio
section
how to style it to be more visible more
prominent more important
and
what to do with covers maybe i will add
some arrows
depending on the way i will react
additional content with
react breaks are always a bit the
motivating when it comes to work but
no that's life during this one and a
half week of break
i took part in coffee and code meeting
coffee and commuting is a frequent camp
meeting of local groups
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love pair programming because you know
you have more eyes
that can look at the same code it's
really useful
especially if you have a problem that
you couldn't solve for for a long time
and all of a sudden this you know
person uh can help you atmosphere coffee
and friends who are also learning to
code and struggling with the same
problems this is really helpful so if
you have a chance to go to local meetups
of people who are learning to code you
should go to the meeting during the
break accumulated new energy for coding
and for new challenges and during the
break i was sightseeing the museums
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the caves
[Music]
[Music]
and beautiful cities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the biggest problem of this week was
that one the week was a bit short
because it started on thursday two
it's a bit hard to come back after
vacation to your normal daily code
routine
this week i was working on styling my
portfolio page
next week i'm going to look deeper into
react and the basics of it because i
want to use
react in my portfolio page
next week i'm also going to
test that the site on various browsers
and devices and fix the box wherever
they appear
and
also
polish a bit the styling and
accessibility so right now after the
break with full tank of energy let's
keep on doing and let's see each other
next week
[Music]
you